hello and welcome to this week in
Android development for July 15 2013 my
name is reto Meier the last week we saw
ankle cot will show us how to make our
apps beautiful by making them more
modern as well as how to use spacing in
typography while chat taught us how to
add curves to our motion good advice
both within your apps and in the club we
also open the mid-year Android developer
survey these surveys are critical for
helping us understand your android
developer challenges and frustrations so
that we can help you overcome them this
year's survey is available in Japanese
and simplified and traditional Chinese
as well as English so you can tell us
exactly what you think in the language
of your choice the writer team have put
together an excellent guide for
efficient data transfers using sync
adapters remember every time you use a
repeating alarm to sync data sundar
kills a bug droid so this is one Android
drank training class you should be
paying close attention to in terms of
apps we saw the latest Google Maps
release cbssports released in apt fans
of the NFL and another app for every
other sport and trulia released an
update to their popular app which
provides Bay Area residents for the way
to shock and alarm their friends and
families in other states and countries
in Android developers live the google
play games tech team talk google play
games and Android design in action
returns with an app redesigned from our
GDG Oslo app clinic which also includes
a guide to design consistency last
week's backstage was delayed until this
week so join the guys for a session of
QA around making apps beautiful before
checking out the last dev bite in that
series as anchor looks at making your
apps beautiful on tablets then on Friday
I'll be taking a look at cricket apps in
the App clinic just in time for
Australia to tie up the ashes within
three days the second test as always you
can go to developers.google.com / live /
android to see what we've got planned
for a dl this coming week that's all for
this week in Android developers for July
15 2013 all day all night I've got the
lights in my eyes